All right.
We are back live. Hello.
Um
It just need to be done.
This release.
Release needs to be done.
Is what it is.
Kernels, vectorization, tracing. What
other things do we do in puffer that
need to be explained?
Loads of text and no visuals again.
Dude, you're looking at an HTML file in
Vim. What do you expect?
Hey Jess.
Like I'm working on the release.
Once four is out and once I get some
rest.
Things don't have to be complicated.
My guy, you're literally talking to the
person who has done more than
not more than anyone.
There is Costa who's awesome and
actually Karpathy O G.
But you wouldn't be able to name more
than like two or three other people
who've done more to simplify this field
than I have.
Okay?
We replaced 3.3 million lines of PyTorch
with 5,000 lines of CUDA.
I'm literally just write I'm writing
documentation to explain everything
right now.
Your Python version here is dead.
Python was making it more complicated
even though people think it was making
it simpler.
C O S T A, if you read the guide you
would have seen his stuff.
Play in RL. Yeah, exactly, Jess.
Costa is awesome.
Let's try.
Dude, I'm pretty stupid sometimes. You'd
be surprised.
At least being me, it doesn't feel like
I'm doing genius [ __ ] with puffer. It
actually just feels like I'm looking
around and everyone's eating crayons for
some reason.
>> Yeah.
That's fair dress.
Oh, okay. So, let me explain to you what
I'm doing in that case. I work on
PufferLib. PufferLib is a reinforcement
learning library that is very, very
fast.
Um we do research on new algorithms. We
write lots of simulations.
We do a lot of custom infrastructure.
Everything is kind of co-optimized
around being very fast. And this means
that now you can do with PufferLib today
on one GPU at home
uh what used to take like a massive
cluster and a whole team in order to do
just 2 years ago. Uh the reason I sound
very annoyed is because this is like
right before release and I've been
crunching for the last many weeks here
in order to get this thing out. And it's
a lot of just like fiddly pre-release
work that is very, very boring and uh
very irritating. And I'm pretty much
ready to just have this thing done, take
a little bit of time off, and then
prepare for the next work that's coming
up. Because we have all sorts of cool
plans for new research and new
algorithms, but I don't get to start any
of that until this release is done.
So, that's why I sound annoyed. Um
if I sound condescending, I guarantee
you I'm really not with this stuff. It's
actually very easy to learn this. We've
had brand new programmers even get into
this stuff. And basically anybody who's
interested in RL and has a even a little
bit of technical background can do it
now.
Um
so, that's the story around here. I
stream all the dev. I stream all the
research. And sometimes in order to keep
myself sane, I stream stuff like writing
the docs pre-release.
Because occasionally we'll have people
that work on PufferLib like drop into
the chat and ask questions, and I do
passively answer stuff like that as
well.
Simulations.
Here are a few of them.
We use a lot of games in research. Games
are really good for RL because they're
interpretable. Uh the RL doesn't care if
it's driving a car. This is used by
multiple self-driving companies. Most
developed with NYU. We have a drone sim.
We have multiple people who have this
using using this to put it on real drone
hardware.
And then you can see we have a whole
bunch of game environments. Game
environments are very useful.
Uh we also have built professionally
stuff in finance, commerce, games as
well. Uh robotics.
Any others?
Uh defense, couple other things.
But most of the public demos are games
because games are really easy to
interpret, which makes them great for
research.
The key to these that makes them
different from just like normal game
programming is they run about a million
times faster.
I mean, we have like stuff deployed for
clients, sure.
Um but these like these are running
right in your browser.
Obviously, they'll run faster locally.
But it's a research toolkit.
As in, can I use the simulations? Yes.
I it's all open source.
Yeah, it's all open source.
Uh with this one, this is the only one I
believe that's different. If you hold
control,
or you just tap control, now I'm playing
it here.
So, I'm playing it here,
right? So, it doesn't move. But if I tap
control again, the neural net will take
over.
Yeah.
It's a little neural net that runs in
your browser. The source code for all of
these is on the GitHub.
Um we actually have a really cool
experiment running on this right now.
It's for a trillion time steps.
We'll probably be done tomorrow.
We have a few new environments that are
getting merged in soon and
uh I mean, the really the main, main
thing is that
the next update makes stuff like 5x
faster.
So, that'll be fun. It's almost done.
We're aiming to release it in less than
a week.
>> How many years is one T for Nural Mamo?
Uh
I think it's like 16 or 17,000 years
worth of sim data, Jess.
But like the thing is we're going to be
able to run 10 trillion if we get rid of
the con encoder.
Like Nural Mamo, it's actually
completely just bottlenecked by the
stupid cons.
So for if I just pick breakout for
instance,
oops.
Why is it not loading?
There we go.
Okay, so here if I hold shift, you have
to hold left shift for most of them.
Nural Mamo, you tap left control. It
says right here.
Doesn't it?
Uh
That's weird. It used to say down right
here that you need to tap left shift.
I'll add that back in.
I don't know why the uh
Yeah, it used to say that you have to
hold shift. Let me add that back.
Oh, press shift to take control.
Yeah, it is. It's right there.
Locally? Well, locally you got to set it
up.
And uh locally you can run
it's the build ocean script.
I should add it so that you can control
eval mode.
I think it's easier to do now without
torch.
I'm trying to not like
give myself more work for the release
though.
We're basically already capped.
Uh that would be try another browser.
Are you just on Chrome?
It should definitely work on anything
that has a
a a GPU.
Some of the Ms probably require some
form of GPU for shaders.
And I don't think all of them do though.
Uh that is a warning only.
It still renders, right?
The WebGL is kind of weird here cuz this
is
it renders. Yeah, ignore the warning
then there. So it's a little bit weird
for the web build version. These are
written in C
and they're compiled to uh to web
assembly with emscripten.
So the web assembly packing is a little
weird.
Um
you know, obviously we don't train on
the browser version of the environment.
We train on the local versions. The web
versions are mostly just so you can
embed demos and show them off.
>> have to keep holding.
Well, they're just demos, right?
They are They're just demos.
It's not intended to be like
a game website.
Uh we use our tech in like a ton of
different applications across
industries.
So, the thing that people don't usually
understand about RL
is like
it's harder to train an agent to play
2048 well, for instance, than it is to
train an agent to fly a drone.
So, we have a number of environments
that actually
uh are very, very good tests of how good
your learning algorithm is.
Like Neural MMO 3, for instance, this is
basically a harder problem than is used
in anywhere in research in the vast
majority of industry.
Like the driving environment here would
be considered like a only medium
complexity problem, and this is used by
actual driving companies.
Like self-driving companies.
So, the things that people think are
hard are often not the things that are
actually hard.
And we have the environments that we
have for research for a reason.
This is actually the core problem that a
lot of um
that sort of plagued a lot of the field
in reinforcement learning is people
really did not have a good grasp of
which tasks are informative uh as to
when your methods will generalize versus
which ones are not.
See, like we're deleting a lot of docs
now, but I think that's a good thing cuz
it's just like most of the stuff you
don't like you just don't need to do
anymore.
No, the visualizations show the trained
model.
Uh we do not do training in the browser.
You have to download PufferLib to train
locally.
It's quite fast, though. You know, many
of the models can be trained in like
seconds or tens of seconds to minutes.
And in Puffer 4, which is the release
I'm working on, many of the models are
literally just trained in seconds.
Really, the um
the demos on the website are mostly just
meant to show you neural nets that are
completing a variety of different tasks
and that have been trained with
PufferLib.
Yeah, they're not the best models. They
haven't all been updated, but many of
them are quite good.
So, Jess, I'm finding myself just
deleting half of the docs because like
you no longer need to do this stuff
anymore.
Like, you know, you had to go write like
a binding file, and then you had to go
write the Python file, and then you had
to like edit the environment.py.
None of that stuff exists anymore.
Why can't I play against the models
where it trains me or I train it?
Uh well, for some of them you can sort
of play against the model, though most
of them are single-player games.
Uh there are some the multi-agent things
you can do.
But,
the reason that you can't play against
the model to train it is that the amount
of gameplay data that you would give it
by doing that is essentially
meaningless.
So, these models are trained on like
hundreds of millions of steps worth of
data often, like hours, days, weeks,
sometimes years or decades or more of
simulated data. It happens very quickly
cuz the simulations are run way faster
than real time.
But the amount of data that you would
give them is just very, very low.
And um we can just train them in
simulation on their own.
Uh this is very different from most AI
because most AI that people are familiar
with today requires companies to spend
hundreds of millions of dollars training
them.
And then you need to have a whole bunch
of GPUs to run them.
These are tiny, tiny models that you can
run on a toaster.
And you can train them at home.
So
they're able to complete tasks
a variety of tasks
with like
less than 1/10,000th of the training
resources.
Yeah, and also they complete different
types of tasks than the the big models
do.
I think material science for sure. Those
are more speculative on my part, Jess.
They're definitely a whole bunch of
random
like industrial problems where it'll
work. I think it's going to be material
science and bio sim. Those will be much
harder, but I think doable.
This is true. Popper might actually do
that.
Uh Jess is one of the contributors.
Jess works on chess.
Several of the contributors will just
sometimes hang out on the stream because
they'll be working on stuff with
their projects and if they get stuck,
it's an easy way to get help. Which is
also one of the reasons I stream.
Jess chess.
Yeah, I know. It's pretty funny. Jess is
very good at chess.
It's just like Karpathy was uh you know,
the head of self-driving for a while.
Hold under so I can become the smartest
person in the world.
Yeah, part of getting good is just not
being afraid to be very, very dumb for a
very long time.
You know how much dumb stuff I do on
stream, man?
Like I got a Stanford bachelor's, I got
an MIT PhD, and I do constantly stupid
[ __ ]
on stream all the time.
It's part of learning.
And it's part of building [ __ ] that
works.
What is Maman MIT?
I didn't know the name of the Eliza
creator. That's funny.
I want to see from today.
Oops.
Ooh.
Making progress.
I was wondering cuz I got eight reps
earlier today.
Reinforcement learning is the exact same
as strength training.
Turns out.
Wrote an if statement with a variable
that's always false one. My guy, when I
was at Stanford, I overheard a couple of
like freshman girls saying like, "Oh my
god, I replaced my if statement with a
while loop and then my program just
worked. Isn't that so weird?"
>> [laughter]
Custom models built from scratch,
congratulations. These are custom models
built from scratch.
So, we're in the right spot.
Uh
technical reasons for problems with
common sense answers.
Bit broad-reaching theories are very
shiny.
Yeah, but like
half of academia does that, man.
More than half of it.
Why do I need a tool and library to
build from scratch?
Uh you can go ahead and try it, man.
This stuff is hard.
Like it's you're not just like typing a
100-line PyTorch model.
Well, I mean puffer is more so like
it's just straight-up not possible to
write an efficient training
implementation with something like
torch.
And nobody's written a simpler training
implementation that's this fast.
You can't train high-performance custom
models with LLMs for this [ __ ]
Say the moon isn't real.
Dude,
the thing is if they recorded a clip
saying the moon landing isn't real, it
will be linked forever, you know,
without the it was April Fools' thing.
Well, we got a nice proper thunderstorm
outside.
I wish it were like not terribly
dangerous to go running in
thunderstorms. That would be fun right
about now.
I'd go do a nice easy 5K in this.
It's a crazy storm.
If you see the roof fly off, that's what
happened.
That just lit up right there, right?
Lightning.
Bright as day lightning.
>> have surge protectors.
I don't know if you can see it, right?
It's behind here.
There are
like
600 lbs of UPS's.
I actually don't think my personal
desktop is on them, funny enough, but
everything else is fine.
Yeah, there are a lot of applications
for RL just, but like
we also have to just make RL less crap,
and then it'll be way easier to figure
it all out.
Probably not just, but it will make a
hell of a difference.
I'd be way less stressed with the
thunder, to be honest, if I weren't um
here with all the uh the GPUs.
They're not waterproof.
But, the roof has been good so far.
Is that room just weights and GPUs?
Pretty much.
I mean, I've got my desk and stuff in
here as well.
You can see I've got a
decent little office area.
The pretty like the awesome thing about
this place is even when I'm being too
lazy and not working out properly, I
still end up doing a few sets here and
there throughout the day. So, like I've
been relatively lazy for the last couple
weeks cuz I've been crunching for
release. And I've still just PR'd my
bench today today, at least my um
max reps for two plates.
I have like a very small little
kitchenette
with uh a coffee maker,
couple things, fridge.
What are we thinking about something
like this?
I can commit this to the current
version.
What do you think? Any feedback on this?
Obviously, we got to put constellation
on here.
We do need to make the clone time
faster.
Well, that's [ __ ] weird, isn't it?
The wrong names.
I'll write something here, but
How hard was it to get down ML? I've
been doing it since I was like 15.
Very hard.
But it's gotten much easier since then.
And uh there's stuff like puffer around
that makes it even easier.
I don't know if it looks as good on the
browser, to be honest here.
Maybe it does.
Oh yeah, it's probably doing um No, it's
not recording. It's fine.
Disable that recording feature and [ __ ]
but
I think that's pretty freaking cool that
we got that done.
There's some stuff we'll have to fix up
tomorrow.
Let's take a quick look at our um
at our run.
This should be almost done.
Oh yeah, that's soda right there. Look
at that.
Probably like 9.4-ish or something.
And it's done in an hour 45 minutes.
Pretty cool.
I'll leave that be. That is 970 billion
steps.
On the tiny box. I can literally hear
the experiment running behind me with
the GPUs on that box.
And this is going to be so cool to just
have constellation
on the website, you know?
Yeah, it'll be so nice to just have
this.
Yeah, it's not twinkling, I think.
Oh, it is, but it's not hm.
I think maybe the shaders are different.
Whatever, I'll play with it.
But I think that's like
all the major stuff is done, and now
it's just like polish, tweak, bug fix.
Basically got everything else done, cuz
we got all the other Ms that were fiddly
to port working.
For the most part.
I think I've done well enough. It's
9:00.
I think I call it for the night.
And then um I get up tomorrow.
I think tomorrow we mostly just like
start testing [ __ ] and fixing little
things and stabilizing, etc., etc.
I think that's the play.
We make sure we have super solid stable
puffer.
And then I have Thursday, Friday,
Saturday to do that.
Clean up docs, clean up puffer, up
release, clean up setup issues.
Get feedback from all of you.
Let me fix the Twitter link before I
forget.
All right, yeah, we're going to call it
for the day.
Thank you, folks.
I'm exhausted.
Three more days and we'll be